and I think that this is very helpful
discussion and I just want to take it
to our our general theme
how a naturalist approaches and I think
it's it's coming out here but I just
want to see if I'm right about this how
a naturalist approach approaches the
domain of morality and how naturalist
thinks about whether there is such a
thing as moral knowledge and if so what
kind of knowledge it is I think that's
what's been emerging here and I want to
actually I just happen to have this in
front of me and something that I passed
confer this is a quote from John Dewey
and I think it I want to put it into
contrast with what most people out of
this room think that moral knowledge is
because I think that most people think
moral knowledge has something to do with
grounding and in particular has to do
with theological grounding and this is
Dewey says this in this is 1922 he says
moral science is not something with a
separate province it is physical
biological and historic knowledge placed
in a humane context where it will
illuminate and guide the activities of
men and so that's a very what we've
called Flossie non-foundation holistic
view and that's I think what's being
supported by several most of the people
here have been speaking it's that
Aristotle says is that the Knik ended
the Nicomachean ethics actually he says
it's a it's something like this that's
it he just says it's we can't ask for
the same precision in ethical or
political discourse and actually at the
end of nicotine ethics he says now I've
told you all what I think about ethics
like what virtues should be inculcated
in the children which ones are good
ideas which ones are better ideas than
others and now I better go on and do
politics because you can't do X without
a notion of a good society and that if
and you could easily imagine if our
stall had written about politics first
he would have ended that book by saying
now I need to go back and tell you in a
more fine-grain way about sort of what
we should say about individuals and
about so but I think here what I wanted
to point out to people this is a
conception of ethical if there is
ethical knowledge of what we would say
is kind of practical knowledge that we
do by conversations sometimes just to
ourselves but sometimes as Dan was
saying we're trying to agree about what
norms should govern our activity and
what we should do next as a group and
it's it's not grounded
a sense of grounded in self-evident
axioms that have wide swaths that
everyone can agree on and it is
historical I think that's the important
thing about the Dewey thing an important
thing about what Rebecca was saying and
I call your attention to the fact that
there are more than one there's more
than one group who actually challenged
this kind of I think naturalistic view
one are the people and this is important
about Hume and I just want and not that
anyone's brought it up but in the famous
passage where David Hume says you can't
go from is--is to Ott's he's actually
talking I mean something that makes some
people think that it's naughty to do
ethics at all like what are we doing and
this would be bad for a naturalist like
when we say things like you you ought to
tell the truth like where's that where's
the fact that that corresponds to and if
you have a certain kind of view about
the world some people would say if your
scientistic I'm gonna get awake my
colleague up if your scientistic there's
nothing that that corresponds to so what
hole does it have for a naturalist and
this is of course the worry that the
dusty asking worried that if there is no
God than everything's allowed and humans
actually talking about this he he's
talking in the treatise on human nature
when he says you can't go for his dogs
that is you can't demonstrate he
actually uses the language you can't
demonstrate moral facts meaning you
can't deduce them and he's talking about
clerics they're always trying to do this
they tell you things like God said such
and so you want to do such and so but
that would be wrong to do and and then
he goes on for 200 more pages in the
treatise or 150 to do what we would call
moral philosophy moral thinking he just
doesn't try to demonstrate anything
because that's not what ethics does it
doesn't have and so this would go back
to I think Stevens point about it's an
area or a zone of human life where it
involves a very complex negotiations
about what we ought to do next what our
good ideas may be the way to put it is
it involves you know reasonable people
talking in reasonable ways about what
they're seeing about their own nature
what they're seeing about what the world
is calling upon them to think or do and
trying to resolve
applicated practical problems but I call
your attention the fact that people like
Sam Harris which which and this is true
of Elwell ed Wilson did this to in on
human nature he claimed to be able to
derive moral norms from certain facts
these would be facts about human nature
and the point is that in either case
it's just a logical point you can't
actually derive them in the logical
sense but what you can do is you can say
things like given our nature of people
who are partial to our loved ones and
our families we ought to think about
accommodating this somehow in our
morality in almost every great world
tradition Confucianism is a good example
but our traditions are good examples
have tried to accommodate this we we
don't even I think we shouldn't think
that there are algorithms to do this we
should think that these are complex
kinds of practical negotiations that we
make with ourselves and with with others
but notice that then says ethics is not
a separate domain of knowledge it's
probably continuous with Prudential and
practical knowledge of all other kinds
of sorts it just maybe has to do with
matters of perhaps greater importance or
what we take to be greater importance
you